pretty the reviewers bringing out Jorge
Lansky
barely Jordan is overcome with emotion
in this moment
not since Spock looked at a reading on
the enterprise you you know I will say
that you and I this is a natural
chemistry and one of the first people to
say we have to put this on film cuz he
watched you and I go back and forth in
the hallways years and years ago was
Frank smiley said we have to just put a
camera on this and he did and that's
when the cult of Jordan grew is that
true yes this was during the writers
strike early 2008 yeah I don't know why
you're carrying a microphone I have in
mind clip to me it's modern technology
you can have two hands-free and
articulate as you will
during the ryder strike we weren't doing
a sketch comedy and we were trying to
think of ideas and one of the producers
who's here in the back still Frank
smiley came up with the idea of just
kind of putting a camera on us and
seeing what happened it was just like a
shot in the dark and it went well yeah
and I can't tell you how many people I
don't know what your experience is
walking through the world but mine I
have so many people come up to me and
say what's the deal with Jordan and I'm
saying I can be anywhere in the world
I've been in the Arab Emirates I've been
in Mexico I have been in the Pacific Rim
and dureth different places and people
want to talk to me about Jordan and they
want to know is he invented is he really
this guy I would say that what we saw
tonight was 98% real you sometimes I
think you put a little English on the
ball but I think for the most part it is
really you and it freaked me out when
you started laughing because you're your
face becomes that of the Joker you get
this weird unnatural expression on your
face you can't stop laughing and you
look like a complete madman it's this
the scariest thing I think I've seen in
my adult life is you just laughing
because it's so unnatural how do you
respond it's the subtle stuff that gets
me so when Conan really laughs it'll
start with like a little twitch when I
see that switch that's kind of what sets
me off okay you know when you're fired
you